[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien écoutez une journée magnifique
d'abord une météorologie très favorable
c'était pas le cas au milieu de semaine
encore vendredi ici tomber des cordes
donc on a pu voir la qualité du terrain
qui en moins de 24 heures à
intégralement sécher d'un point de vue
accès c'était un point très important
pour nous vérifiez que l'accès
Jean-Pierre Timbaud pour le public
fonctionnait bien et que l'accès rue à
la colère était également utilisé pour
les accréditer et toute la partie
technique bien écoutez le fonctionnement
est à 100% optimal la partie transport
est très réussie on aura des points de
réglage c'est aussi le but de ce genre
de test
[Musique]
donc on a vu qu'on avait un petit point
de faiblesse sur l'arrivée en gare de
Saint-Quentin et la reprise des navettes
c'est un point qu'on avait déjà signalé
d'ailleurs en face préparatoire auprès
d'Île-de-France mobilité on a encore
quelques endroits peut-être ou les
passages pour les spectateurs sont un
peu étroits je pense sur un nécessité
tout en respectant les règles
écologiques qui sont très strictes de
les allergir un petit peu on est fin
prêt à entreprendre la dernière phase de
travaux celle qui nous amènera jusqu'aux
Jeux Olympiques dans maintenant un petit
peu plus de 10 mois
[Musique]
l'héritage on le voit déjà c'est déjà le
fait d'avoir une piste de VTT d'avoir
expulsé de ce lieu le maximum de plantes
invasives il y a eu un très gros travail
écologique qui a été qui a été fait
ensuite nous aurons la création pendant
un an des pistes complémentaires ces
pistes qui vous permettront à vous et à
moi et à l'ensemble des 5 continents et
de ceux qui viendront de toute la France
de pratiquer un VTT pas seulement de
haut niveau mais du débutant jusqu'au
plus haut niveau avec je le rappelle 5
couleurs de piste différentes un peu
comme au ski un des bleus des jaunes des
Verts des rouges des Noirs le meilleur
héritage ça sera de le rendre aux
familles pour qu'elles puissent se
promener et en même temps voir des
sportifs de haut niveau de points au
niveau qui utiliseront ces pistes
[Applaudissements]